einen wunderschönen guten Tag Christ
guten Morgen also okay ver alles bestens
ne eine bei mir nicht ne die Infektion
von bronchial Katar bis bis bis bis
nasenkirmis alles da schlimme Sache
Erkältung ich bin so alt 47 früher waren
die Sachen kurzfristig heute sind
langfristig früher dann man Erkältung
heute h man es vereitert okay wir fahren
mal mit diesem gläsernen Aufzug danke
schön Frage ist oft am Anfang des
Interviews du man sich oder sizt man
sich Hintergrund ist branchenüblich ist
eigentlich das du man ist am Set und
sofort ich bin der Ingo ich bin genau
eigentlich üblich was machen wir ja wir
duzen un natürlich aber es gibt auch
irgendwie so ein Wort dafüri siezen und
dann gibt so soen
du ja ich habeadech in so Roman ja da
sagt man Ingo wie geht's ihnen denn aber
ich lustige Geschichte erlebt in
Berliner eiscaffe da habe ich auch den
der Bedienung junger Mann auch gesagt
dann gibst du mir noch ein bisschen von
dem Schokoladeneis dreht er sich um und
sagte wirklich freundlich aber ich
möchte nicht geduzzt werden von ihnen
ich bin schließlich locker über 30 der
meinte das richtig ernst und ich wusste
jetzt nicht ob ich sagen soll machst du
elich ein Schaden oder ob ich sagen
sollte entschuldigigen Sie bitte dass
ich sie gedutzt habe weil der hatte so
seriös gesagt ich möchte nicht von jedem
von euch gedutzt werden dass ich dachte
da habe ich wahrscheinlich einen Fehler
gemacht ich bin über 30 möchte nicht von
von ihnen behandelt werden wie eine
kleine Barbiepuppe oder so also musste
ich sagen entschuldigen sie bitte dann
hätte ich gerne von Ihnen noch ein
Kügelchen Schokoeis dazu also da war ich
wirklich schockiert ich bin
normalerweise echt so ein duztyp also da
also wir duzen uns ja finde ich schön ja
unsere erste Frage in den allermeisten
Fällen wie ist die Lage die Lage ich
habe gestern in
in im Fernsehen gehört ich gucke ja
selten Fernsehen weil ich so die Zeit
nicht habe wegen meiner ganzen sozialen
Kontakte aber im Hotel genieße ich das
dann immer wenn ich dann abends mir
irgendwie so ein so ein chinesisches
food aufmachen kann im Bademantel dann
vom F sitzen kann Nachrichten gucken und
die sagten dass die Wirtschaftslage
jetzt
ungefähr so sein wird wie seit seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg so schlecht und ich
muss sagen das Schlechte natürlich auch
auf unseren berufeder ne ganz klar ich
werde mal sagen die Lage ist
äh nicht hoffnungslos aber schon ganz
schön roten Bereich ir lich gibt's
weniger Buchung im Moment ja ich ich ja
klar man merkt das schon deutlich
deutlich weil du bist ja jemand der
nimmt was was kommt also wenn ich du
hast x Filme hast du gedreht Serien
komedyserien alles mögliche prom pilgern
habe ich gesehen also das prom pilgern
da muss ich noch drauf eingehen weil das
das war wirklich so das war da da war da
hätte man da wä man doof gewesen also
wirklich richtig doof wenn man es nicht
gemacht hätte er erstens war es
finanziell eine klasse Angebot weil im
Prinzip jeden Wandertag jeden Tag des
wandern wie ein Drehtag bezahlen wollten
und das war ist natürlich ein tolles
Angebot und dann muss ich ganz ehrlich
zugeben ohne mich rausreden zu wollen
mit diesen pilgern war ich schon immer
irgendwie unterwegs da war ich schon
immer irgendwie finde ich eigentlich
interessant irgend ich eigentlich sollte
man eiglich mal tun und so und ich bin
auch so ein Typ der eigentlich so viele
soll sollte man es im Keller hat dass
man da schon könnte man schon irgendwie
ein halbes Leben mitleben was hast du im
Keller sollte man ach sollte man ich
sollte mal ne ich sollte mal eine
Weltreise machen ich sollte mal Yoga
machen ich sollte mal und so und da kam
dieses Angebot mit den Pilgern und sagte
jetzt ist jetzt ist ja cool erstens kann
ich bisschen was verdienen zweitens kann
ich dann gar nicht mehr anders und
drittens ist alles da aber die brauche
ich hab ist gebucht ich muss hab ein Tag
wo ich loslaufen muss und los und dann
war das ein der GE Letten Erfahrung die
ich irgendwie in meinen 47 Jahren Leben
gemacht habe ich habe z.B so bin z so
ein rückenmensch ich habe also tierisch
verspannte Rückenmuskulatur Bandscheiben
Vorfall immer gerne mal beim Schlafen
grundsätzlich eine eingeschlafene
Schulter die schäft immer eher ein als
ich und wacht viel später auf und nach
diesem wandern drei Wochen pilgern zum
ersten Mal komplett schmerzfrei ich
komme nach Hause merke gar nicht und
merke irgendwann mal abends we ich mich
wieder auf meine normale Seite drehen
will tut gar nicht weh irre also da
wirklich was gebracht und die Leute zu
Hause also die meisten wieder getroffen
habe die sagt du bist irgendwie
verändert irgendwie mental strahlst du
anderes aus danach habe ich natürlich
ein bisschen nachgehagt du bist nicht
mehr so hektisch im Moment man sieht ja
es hat sich wieder alles verändert ich
bin wieder genauso hektisch wie
früher aber das hat wohl schon irgendwie
wirklich was dieses Jahr würde ich ins
Auge fassen noch mal zu tun wow wirklich
wow wirklich das ist jetzt auch gar
nicht so ein Ding dass man dass man da
irgendwie drüber lachen sollte weil das
das war der Sinn des Ganzen eben halt
dieses ganze diese ganze Blinky
Gesellschaft so Telefon Handy SMS E-Mail
was wir alles haben uns ständig
irgendwie präsent macht uns fordert
irgendwie zu antworten ne in
Kommunikation zu treten fällt da weg die
Vereinbarung war ich melde mich einmal
am Tag zu Hause ob alles okay ist der
Rest war schweigen und das hat richtig
gut getan richtig gut getan du hast ja
auch eine Menge Drogenerfahrung ist das
wie eine Droge so eine Wanderung oder
was unterscheidet es
das unterscheidet das dass man dass man
dass man bei dieser Pilgerei war das
eher etwas etwas was auflöst etwas was
Knoten
wegmacht und die Drogengeschichten sind
natürlich immer Sachen die die kom also
letztendlich konsequenterweise
untergestrich immer Knoten machen und
zwar
gesundheitliche Knoten also Knoten im
Sinne von negativen
Strangulation gesundheitlich finanziell
sozial letztendlich auch kopfmäßig und
so
da ist das PG natürlich wesentlich
gesünder um das um das mal zu erklären
was das zu zu tun hat mit me mit der
Zeit in der ich groß geworden bin wo ich
ja immer unheimich stolz darauf bin weil
ich das irgendwie weil es weil es
erklärbar ist weil das ich in der
punkzeit groß geworden bin die war für
mich damals als werdender Künstler ich
wusste damals zu der Zeit ja noch nicht
dass ich irgendwie was mit Kunst zu tun
haben wollte warum mal die die
Tierpräparator zu werden das war die
Tierpräparator Zeit wo ich irgendwie
auch sicherlich Polizeipräsident hätte
werden können oder z morbidem ja ja ne
es war einfach deswegen weil ich nicht
wusste was ich tun sollte meine Kumpels
irgendwie sind irgendwo sich bewerben
gegangen und ich bin Hal mitgegangen was
soll ich tun und der eine sagte noch ich
geh mal zum Tierpräparator Wettbewerb
komm ich mit vielleicht wird es was ne
aber ansonsten war man war man wirklich
so frei und dann kommt natürlich das
dazu die Gedanken sind frei man fängt an
zu sagen wir machen das jetzt hier und
mit unserer ganzen Kraft und das wird so
so kraftvoll sein dass wir natürlich
irgendwie verpuffen wie kleine Sternchen
im Universum wir haben unsere ganze
Kraft jetzt hier gelassen da wären wir
keine 60 das sind ver glücklich W wir 30
werden und dann gibt geht's hier und
dann gehbt's hier und so ne und das hat
natürlich dann auch was damit zu tun
gehabt excessiv zu leben mit Drogen zu
tun gehabt die die gar nichts gebracht
haben S von weiter kommen die sondern
sondern einfach nur dazu gehörten wie
z.B sagen wir mal eine Fliege zum
Smoking gehörte einfach dazu und da man
eben halt eigentlich ein armer Hund war
was wirklich finanziell auch so gemeint
war bebst natürlich meistens bei Bier
Schnaps und
Haschisch Kokain und diese ganzen
Geschichten waren uns einfach viel zu
teuer und wenn es mal dazu kam dann
haben wir natürlich tierisch einen boah
wie geil jetzt sind wir ganz oben ne
jetzt sind wir hier Rock and Roll und so
deswegen S ist die Geschichte mit den
Drogenerfahrung manchmal wenn Sie den
Fokus gezerrt wird ganz oft irgendwie
sehr übertrieben weil man das manchmal
so ein bisschen das Gefühl hat da war
gar nichts anderes ne obwohl ich will es
nicht verschweigen weil es wie schon
gesagt auch einfach zu der Tendenz
gehört dass ich einfach auch solange wie
ich in der Öffentlichkeit stehe bin ich
ein Stück weit öffentlicher Mensch und
da versuche ich den mal dann auch
möglichst ehrlich mit meinem Klientel
Zuschauer umzugehen um den nicht
irgendwie zu erzählen wie toll es mir
geht wie glücklich ich bin wie man
sollte nur so sein wie ich dann wäre
alles besser so so so solche Geschichten
will ich gar nicht jetzt auf Trapez
bringen weil so ist es nicht sondern wie
ist es ja es ist halt so dass ich eben
halt irgendwie auch in dieser
Öffentlichkeit in der ich stehe eben Hal
auch sehr als sehr verletzlicher Mensch
unterwegs bin dass ich mit vielen Sachen
sag mal vielleicht sogar schlechter
zurecht komme als als so ein gewisser in
Ermangelung eines besseren Wortes
Durchschnittsmensch das ist aber trotz
all dem zu meinem Paket ing ne dazug
gehört das ist einfach so ich bin so
geschnürt und und kann da nicht einfach
auspacken und einpacken so wie ich
lustig bin dann muss schon einfach auch
zugeben dass auch meine
schauspielerische Intensität oder intens
natürlich auch viel mehr mit Leid und
Trauer zu tun hat als mit Lust und Spaß
also auch wenn man mich oft als Comedien
sieht oder so hat nichts damit zu tun
dass ich im Grunde genommen eigentlich
ein lustiger Mensch bin also ich bin so
nicht so ein bumsfalderat Typ wie es
vielleicht manchmal so rüber kommt du
hast gerade gesagt Leid und Trauer
gehören zu diesem Beruf ja ja warum
warum so ist das so wichtig na ja ich
glaube was einfach eben halt einfach
ganz oft so unterschätztes Ding ist was
man so an an an also Leid und Trauer so
ein bisschen so weggeschoben wir jetzt
genauso wie der Tod und alle diese
Diskussionen in unserer Gesellschaft das
eine ziemliche triebfehler die wir
eigentlich haben nur wird eben gerne
davon weg geguckt weil in unserer
Gesellschaft natürlich meistens
derjenige ein toller Typ ist der gut
drauf ist ne und durch diese ganzen
Geschichten die wir momentan im
Fernsehen als erfolgreiche Formate
bezeichnen sehen wir das ja immer wieder
ist ja auch nicht schlimm we sie werden
ja geguckt also braucht man sie auch
aber du durch Deutschland such den
Superstar und und und Topmodels und so
da wird ein mir immer wieder suggeriert
schön sein lustig sein gut drauf sein
dann läuft es schon und dadurch wird
imand glaube ich ganz doll so ein so so
eine ganz wichtige Triebfeder in uns so
wie Sexualität auch Lebensfreude auch
dieser dieses dieses depressive Teilchen
in uns manchmal so ein
bisschen in den Keller gestopft und da
irwi mundtot gemacht ne hast du den
Eindruck dass mit der Dauer des Lebens
die Trauer
ansteigt sag mal dass man so die
negativen gute Frage ja also man ist auf
jeden Fall so dass ich die Ergebnisse
die Ereignisse mehren sich und da kann
natürlich dann auch natürlich
dementsprechend mehrere mehr schlechte
Sachen dabei sein können natürlich auch
dementsprechend mehr gute dabei sein
aber ich glaube dass was hilft ist das
Alter im Sinne von Weisheit z.B der
Kölner sagen würde kannst ja nichts
ändern ist wird ist z.B ist so ein so
ein primitiver Satz aber der ist
irgendwie schon gar nicht so schlecht
weil es gibt wirklich auch als
philosophische Grundhaltung so ein Ding
wie es gibt die abänderlichen Dinge und
die unabänderlichen Dinge des Lebens
also du kannst s wirklich an Sachen
totlufen wie ein Hamster im Rat du wirst
s nicht ändern ja ich kann natürlich
ändern dass ich nicht mehr als Schwein
durch die Welt laufe ich kann natürlich
ändern dass ich dass ich wenn ich dazu
Lust habe sagen ich habe da jetzt mal
wie ich das in Berlin manchmal mache ich
habe da so meine meine Wege wo ich
einkaufen gehe und da gibt's dann eben
was we ich zehn Penner und von den Zeh
sind immer die vier die kriegen von mir
immer irgendwie den Euro dann hat ja für
mich einfach so kein Zweck den Leuten
gar nichts zu geben da fühle ich mich
dann irgendwie auch doof wenn ich jedem
irgendwas gebe fühle mich auch doof weil
ich irgendwie denke man so eine scheiß
Beliebigkeit und da ist mir aufgefallen
dass ich mich am wohlsten dabei fühle
ich so meine meine Leute habe im Grunde
genommen die von mir irgendwie praktisch
in in in in
in in Symbolismus für alle irgendwie so
dann da immer irgendwie was kriegen das
sind so die abinnerlichen Sachen ich
kann zu meiner zu meinen Kindern besser
werden ich kann mich selber vielleicht
ein bisschen besser behandeln oder mich
besser pflegen das sind so Sachen die
kann ich ändern und
da kann man dann angreifen und das fine
ich dann schon wieder auch sinnvoll und
da finde ich je älter man wird und dann
noch mal auf deine Frage zu kommen je
älter man wird je weiser man wird desto
besser glaubt man glaub ich kann man mit
diesen Störungen ob sie mental sind oder
oder gesundheitlich umgehen dass man
sagen kann wenn ich das jetzt tue weiß
ich genau fühle mich die nächste Woche
irgendwie scheiße deswegen lass ich sein
under mach mach erst gar nicht und das
reicht mir eigentlich schon da wür ich
schon sagen wenn ich das so erreicht
habe dass ich so so ein lebensschema
entdeckt habe wo ich weiß wenn ich mich
davor Schütze dann geht's mir besser wie
kommt deine Familie mit dir zurecht als
Mensch der das alles so bewusst
erlebt ja das liegt natürlich auch oder
das ist fängt natürlich da an wo ich
mich schon mal als Familienvater schon
so gar nicht so richtig einstufen kann
weil man fragt m natürlich wie gehst Du
z.B deinen Kindern um erziehst du da
gehen bei mir schon die Alarmglocken an
weil ich eigentlich merke ich jetzt sie
gar nicht ich ich bin eigentlich gar
nicht so jemand der dann wirklich da wir
ja das ist ein scheiß Thema weil weil
bist du zu sehr Künstler dazu Scheiße ja
ich wei ist die Familie mehr so ein
Anhängsel was jetzt einfach entstanden
ist und mitkommen das ist gut also das
mit dem Anhängsel und dem entstanden ist
ist richtig das ist richtig ja also ich
bin nicht auf der suche gewesen mir mir
wie ich das z. meine Eltern kenne die
gesagt haben wir wollten ganz klar sagen
19 20 21 wollte ich meine meine Lehre zu
Ende haben da wollte ich ein netten Mann
und nette Frau kennenlernen und eine
Familie gründen das hatte ich nie aber
das hatten viele nie glaube ich das ist
irgendwie das ist das hatte ich nie und
ich bin in einer unglaublich netten
Familie groß geworden wo ich eigentlich
normalerweise sagen müsste wenn ich mich
von außen betrachte das war eigentlich
eigentlich so ein schöner Hafen so ein
so eine eine sichere Zeit die mir da
geboten wurde eigentlich müsste ich den
großen Anspruch haben weiterzugeben aber
ich hatte nie das Bedürfnis zu sagen ich
brauche jetzt jetzt irgendwie zwei
Kinder oder ein Kind oder drei Kinder
den ich das wiedergeben kann ich hatte
kein kein nicht diesen Input und dann
waren sie plötzlich da und wie ist das
jetzt es ist natürlich so dass ich
natürlich ganz ehrlich gesagt und das
natürlich jetzt wieder blablabla aber es
ist wirklich nicht so gemeint ich lieb
sie natürlich von ganzem ganzem Herzen
und wenn irgendwas passieren würde was
was was tragisch wäre ich hätte wirklich
nicht die geringste Ahnung wie ich damit
umgehen würde wenn ich jetzt parallelen
schlagen soll zu solchen amläufen die es
ist
eine also eine eine emotionale
Katastrophe ich habe nie na also da muss
ich wirklich sagen ich bin wirklich
selten sprachlos aber da bin ich einfach
sprachlos auch wenn Kinder wegkommen und
man weiß nicht wo sie sind oder so
äh da bin ich manchmal habe ich manchmal
schon den Verdacht dass ich dass ich
wenn ich über mich nachdenke schon
deswegen keine Kinder wollte weil ich
mir einfach auch diesen Schmerz hätte
irgendwie ersparen wollen einfach gar
nicht diese Verluste haben wenn ich da
kear nichts zum Verlieren habe und jetzt
habe ich Sie da wenn ich an meine beiden
denke wenn ich mir vorstellen W diese
Gesichte W irgendwann mal nicht mehr in
meinem Leben
das also katastrophal es ist ja schon
alleine deswegen weil ich natürlich
jetzt irgendwie ein Vergleich den man
sicherlich irgendwie total schändlich
findet aber ich hatte z.B mal
Mischlingshund den ich 15 Jahre lang
hatte ich habe deswegen keine Tiere mehr
weil ich diesen Verlust nicht noch mal
erleben will der ist mir dann irgendwann
mal gestorben nach 15 Jahren nur ein
Hund aber das meine ich noch mal mit
deswegen meine Kinder wollen Andau
Katzen und Andau irgendwelche Tiere und
ich verweiß auch gerne D dass die der
Wunsch irgendwie aber das meine ich noch
mal diese ne das war bist du dünnh
heutig ja ja vor allen Dingen irgendwie
bei bei solchen Geschichten die dann
unwiederbringbar sind und und wo da
würde ich auch mit meiner meiner
Philosophen Kacke nicht mehr mitkommen
also ist wie ist und und und und jeder
jedes jeder Anfang auch ein Ende und da
will ich w ich ein ich glaube ich würde
einfach als Mensch komplett
zusammenbrechen auch wenn man die
Probleme jetzt kleiner stand wenn schon
meine meine Tochter jetzt kommen würde
mit 14 würde sagen ich habe da ein
49jährigen Typen kennengelernt der Macht
in in
Afghanistan neuen Hotdog Laden auf den
habe ich mich verliebt mit dem gehe ich
jetzt brech die Schule ab morgen bin ich
weg ich wüsste gar was ich machen sollte
ich wüste natürlich sagen woll bist du
bescheuert gehbt natürlich gar nicht
aber wie ich jetzt sag W sie fest
entschlossen müsste ich sie anbinden
weil ich hätte nicht die geringste
Ahnung wie ich als als erziehen damit
jetzt umgehen müsste oder wenn sie z.B
sagt Papa ich gehe zum ersten Mal raus
in die Disco oder so ne soll ich sagen
pass auf lass s nicht vergewaltigen oder
Pass mal schön auf dass sie nicht iriner
an den Möpse packt oder ich wüste gar
nicht was ich tun sollte ich w in diesen
diesen Fragen bin ich dann einfach
wirklich als Vater komplett überfordert
Idiot hab keine Ahnung wenn sie auf mich
zukommen ich lasse sie auf mich zukommen
in Ermangelung einer besseren Taktik
aber ich wüsste nicht was dann passiert
macht das deine Lebensgefährtin dann ich
denke
ja ich hoffe ja nein es wür es würde ja
sowieso irgendwas passieren also es
würde natürlich irgendwas geschehen aber
aber
wenn ich wenn du mich jetzt einfach so
bewusst jetzt fragst irgendwie wäre ich
irgendwie als erziehender weil du mich
ja jetzt irwie als als instant Papa
ansprachst wä ich nicht vorbereitet und
dann dann bin ich natürlich geneigt zu
sagen wahrscheinlich bin ich meinen
Kindern eher ein Freund ist aber auch
nicht wirklich wah weil ich eben halt
auch bin auch streng also ja ja wenn ich
irgendwie so reinkomme mein Töchterchen
ist ja so wir sind ja eine Patrick
Familie meine Luna meine liebe liebe
lieblingsluna weil sie meine erste ist
meine hat hat ihr eigenes Zimmer ist
auch gerne bei uns und wenn ich manchmal
die Tür aufmach gibt do gar nicht sieht
aus wie bei den Simpsons wie man habe
ich nicht g Date wenn ich das jetzt so
sehen würde würde ich sagen boah ist
schlecht so ist das doch nicht im
richtigen Leben aber ist so Unterhöschen
Socken Turnschuhe überall ne und dann
bin ich schon so wenn ich die Tür hier
nicht mehr aufkriege möchte ich das
sofort innerhalb von den nächsten 10
Minuten irgendwie Ordnung geschaffen
wird und wenn nur in Plastiktüten landet
da kann ich schon auch ne aber ich bin
auch wie schon gesagt also habe also
kein Erziehungskonzept ich möchte dass
meine Kinder gute Menschen werden ich
möchte dass sie z.B Bitte und Danke
sagen dass sie wenn z.B Alter alter
Menschen die U-Bahn Einsteig Platz
anbieten solche Kleinigkeiten und zwar
sie das aus Reflex tun aus Herzensgüte
und nicht weil es irgendwo steht oder
möchte nicht dass sie so so ein was
wollst du soll ich nicht schnutz oder
was das möchte ich nicht da möchte ich
auch alles dagegen tun dass es aber sie
werden halt mit solchen Leuten groß zu
98% glaube ich ne wie ist das dann
überhaupt in der Patchwork family weil
Familie du hast ja
zwei Töchter noch aus der ersten
Beziehung deiner Freundin die Leben auch
bei Euch oder sind unterwegs oder g ganz
genau sieht so aus dass die Luna meine
erste 12 Jahren jetzt in wieder im
Ruhrgebiet wohnt mit meiner Ex-Frau aber
ebenal regelmäßig in Berlin ist mit
ihrem eigenen Zimmer und auch gerne da
ist in Berlin ist dann meine jetzige
Partnerin die eine 20-jährige und einen
zölfjährigen mitgebracht haben der
12jährige wohnt noch bei uns 20-Jährige
ist gerade raus und mit dieser Frau mit
der ich zusammen in Berlin lebe habe ich
jetzt noch mal zusammen einen zwei
jährigen und da e mal alles dabei alles
dabei und und und da haben die Leute
halt immer ach wie schön wie bunt und
und da muss ich wirklich sagen dass ist
das ist wieder sowas wo ich wieder mal
wieder ehrlich sein muss und sagen muss
das es einfach eine unglaublich
erschreckende Arbeit ist von der ich
nicht gewusst habe dass es so ist ich
habe z.B das ist jetzt auch eine Beichte
dafür darauf bin ich auch nicht stolz
aber das muss ich einfach sagen ist z.B
diese Geschichte die man früher mal
gesagt blut ist dicker als blut ist
dicker als Wasser es ist schon so dass
man dass ich nicht ich weiß nicht ob ich
jetzt sagen soll mann oder ich nur aber
es ist schon komisch wenn man
eigengeborene Kinder hat und Kinder hat
die einem die dazuekommen sind oder die
man geschenkt bekommen hat oder die
einem
aufgebordet worden sind wen man sich in
die ich habe mich nicht in in den Jungen
und in die Tochter verliebt ich habe
mich ja in die Frau verliebt und dann
sagt natürlich jeder na ja klar wenn D
in die Frau verliebst dann musst du
natürlich auch alles gleichzeitig lieben
was S mitbringt ist ja Quatsch nicht
dass ich jetzt dem anderen irgendwie
ungerecht bin ganz im Gegenteil manchmal
bin ich sogar
toleranter dem dem den den also den
anderen beiden gegenüber weil ich denke
so wenn ich meinen beiden da irgendwie
netter bin dann fliege ich ja komplett
auf also bin ich manchmal strenger mit
meinen eigenen Kindern blutmäßig nur
damit ich emer zeigen kann so ich bin
gerecht aber mir ist schon oft
aufgefallen dass ich dass ich dass dass
dass meine meine eigenen Kinder mir
einfach irgendwie
automatisch
ich mehr ein Auge zudrücken kann als
wenn es
irgendwie ich also ich bin darüber
unglaublich unglücklich weil weil ich da
nicht gedacht hätte dass ich so bin oder
dass man so ist vielleicht ist es bei
jem so man hört ja immer von allen
Seiten irgendwie das geht ganz einfach
und ich habe gedacht na klar geht das
einfach du hast die Frau lieb sehr lieb
sogar du wirst alles dafür tun dass die
dass es als Beziehung funktioniert also
nimmst du alles mit was da an Ballast
dabei ist in anführungstrichen aber das
war dann plötzlich als der Alltag
eintrat plötzlich schwieriger als ich
erwartet hatte was sagt sie dazu
es ist es ist es ist nicht auffällig
also es ist nicht so dass ich das
auffällig ist sie weiß gar nichts davon
eigentlich wenn wenn ich sie nicht
gebeichet gebeichtet hätte würde sie es
nicht wissen nein weil es ist natürlich
ganz klar dass ich dass ich da als
bewusster Mensch ganz klar weiß dass es
so nicht geht natürlich nicht aber
ist z.B so wenn wenn wenn wenn sagen mal
ganz blöd jetzt der der der der johnny
ist der Sohn von der meiner Frau putzt
ich die Zähne und dann ist er irgendwie
sagen wir mal ist 12 Jahre und ist
irgendwie jetzt gut drauf und dann macht
er irgendwie und spritzt den ganzen
Spiegel V Zahnpasta s er muss das denn
sein mach das jetzt wieder weg wenn
meine Tochter das machen würde würde ich
sagen auch echt man we du mit ein
anderen Haltung es ist die müsstest auch
wegmachen aber es ist irgendwie weiß ich
nicht ich kann es ganz schwer erklären
es ist irgendwie als wenn du irgendwie
wenn de du weißt als als Mensch bewusst
dass du die Gerechtigkeit so setzen
kannst wie sie sein muss das kann ich
auch ganz klar aber im Herzen verzeig
ich einfacher meinen eigenen Kindern als
in anderen Kindern das heißt es gibt
ich sag mal Dinge die unabänderlich sind
auch wenn man es wollte ja ja ja ja ich
kann mich nicht D nicht so richtig
dagegen whren ich weiß ich bin ein
bewusster Mensch darauf bin ich jetzt
wirklich froh und stolz weil ich ih mal
merke hoppla das geht nicht Ingo
vorsichtig also es wird mir nicht
passieren dass D dass den beiden Kindern
Fall fällt ein Brötchen auf die auf die
Erde der eine kriegt einescheuert den
anderen Lob ich dafür das ist natürlich
absolut nicht der Fall aber es ist so
dass ich e merke manchmal meine
Toleranzgrenze größer weil es
blöderweise meine eigenen sind
ja und das ist mit der Patchwork Familie
so dass dass da die Romantisierung
komplett ausfällt das ist wirklich
richtig harte Arbeit und dann kommen
noch so Geschichten wie wir fahen den
Urlaub habt ihr es gut ich sag Horror
der eine will an Strand der andere will
in die Berge der eine will zu Hause
bleiben der eine will Fisch eine will
Pizza der andere will Spaghetti der
andere will gar nichts
Horror und da ist wirklich also nichts
Romantisches dabei und ich will mit
meiner Mutter ich will mit deinem Vater
ich will noch das das kommt noch dazu
und dann noch diese sind noch die Sachen
komm ich kann mit deiner Mutter nicht
ich kann mit deinem Vater nicht wenn D
diese diese diese nichts dazu kommen
also diese diese diese diese negativen
Dinge wo man dann wirklich richtig
schlechte Laune von kriegt wo es wo es
zum Streit führen kann wo es zu zuur
Katastrophe führen kann das ist dann
wirklich richtig schwer und wenn man
dann in in unser Gespräch von vorne noch
mal anzuknüpfen also keine Leitfigur ist
keiner der auf dem Tisch schauen kann
dann ist Ruhe so das kann ich nämlich
nicht doch ich kann schon am Tisch
schauen nur hört keiner ich habe schon
am Tisch gehauen aber mein Arm so dick
und und alle haben nur gesagt PAP was
machst denn du da
ja Leute ich habe auf Tisch ach so ja
also wo war wir stehen geblieben also
komplett ignoriert ne also irgendwie
muss ich da wohl nicht so der Autorität
der also die Autorität ausstrahlen nicht
ausstrahlen müsste um das alles im Griff
zu haben obwohl du ein unglaublich
impulsiver Mensch bist also das hätte
ich jetzt nie erwartet dass man das ich
habe auch nicht erwartet das war für
mich auch wieder so eine Überraschung wo
ich dachte Mensch das gibt's do gar
nicht aber es ist ist so dass ich das
diese Erfahrung schon öfter gemacht habe
dass ich also ich bin wirklich ein Typ
der der der ich bin immer immer vorne
weg auch und immer mit dabei und und und
wenn ich in der Gruppe bin ist meine
Meinung auch gefragt und so weiter aber
letztendlich so das
Alphatier das bin ich glaube ich nicht
leider aber du hättest es eigentlich
gedacht ich hätte es eigentlich gedacht
und und und ich hätte es eigentlich auch
gemocht weil weil wie schon gesagt ich
hab immer so ein bisschen das Gefühl
dass ich eben halt auch dadurch dass ich
eben halt auch so ein Mensch bin der
dadurch verwestert natürlich auch eine
offene Meinung dass ich eben Hal ich
habe bin so ein versteher aber aber im
wirklichen Sinne versteher also wenn jem
wenn ich sage pass auf diese Hose ist
blau dann ist das für mich eine klare
Sache wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sagt
na ja da ist ist aber auch blau mit mit
so ein bisschen weiß drin so dann bin
ich dann weich ich schon auf dann fange
ichon an zu sagen im Prinzip hast du
recht stimmt schon ist übrigens auch was
was ich meinen Kindern gerne mitgeben
würde ein ein was für die fürs Leben und
zwear der Satz der andere könnte auch
recht haben das ist für mich auch ein
grundkern meiner meiner
Lebenseinstellung Achtung Ausrufezeichen
der andere könnte auch recht
haben was haben denn deine Kinder wenn
du da schon mal gelernt hast dass du
kein Alpha Typ bist der sonst noch
mitgegeben was haben die bei dir
verändert als so ein ich sag mal Mensch
der der ja gewöhnt ist sein Ding zu
machen
Entschuldigung ja genau das dass es eben
nicht immer nur darum geht sein Ding zu
machen das haben sie mir auf jeden Fall
mitgegeben weil weil weil mir hat schon
sehr gut gefallen ich habe z.B aufgehört
zu schreiben ich bin früher auch so
kleine theaterstückchen geschrieben
esses Kurzgeschichten aber auch immer
irgendwie mit dem Stempel black schwarz
negativ und da ich eben grundsätzlich
nur dann schaff kann wenn ich
authentisch bin habe ich angefangen zu
merken als ich weiter schrieb wenn ich
diese schwarzen Gedanken oder schwarzen
Geschichten da
weiterspinne kommen irgendwann mal kommt
irgendwann mal der Punkt wo ich mich
entscheiden muss ob ich das was ich da
schreibe auch leben kann oder ob ich das
nur schreibe weil sich gut anhört und
wenn dann der Tag beginnt dann bin ich
plözlich ganz anderer lieb und nett
und haben meine Kinder mich drauf
gebracht dass ich sage ich sagte oder
sagen musste als sie dann da waren
konnte ich diese schwarze Haltung nicht
mehr wirklich durchziehen weil es hätte
irgendwie auf sie abgefärbt weil in
diesen Geschichten ging es immer darum
äh äh das Leben ist eine ein Mann
Mission
die Hölle ist mein natürlicher
Lebensraum solche Geschichten Halt und
und als die Kinder dann da waren ging
das nicht mehr weil dann wä ich nicht
mehr ich hätte es natürlich
weiterschreiben können aber ich hätte es
natürlich auch ich konnte es nicht mehr
mein Leben reinlassen dafür so
authentisch könnte nicht mehr sein weil
sie hätten drunter leiden müssen das
heißt du warst vorher so negativ so ja
das H negativ ich habe meinen Fokus mehr
darauf gerichtet sagen wir mal wenn ich
z.B eine Geschichte über Samstag Nacht
geschrieben hätte gibst bes schet ein
paar Autoren die hätten dann geschrieben
wie sie dann irgendwie Cocktail und dann
betrunken und dann in diesem betrunkenen
hätten sie Mädchen kennengelernt dann
wär sie mit ihr nach Hause gegangen am
nächsten Morgen wer sie wach geworden
und wären zu dritt im Bett und hi war
das ein Abend das wäre der Samstagabend
gewesen mein Samstagabend wä dann eher
so bei Trainspotting geendet oder
zumindest in dieser dass man dann
vielleicht morgens aufgewacht wäre und
dann hätte die Frau mit der man nach
Hause gegangen wäre plötzlich keinen
Kopf mehr gehabt oder irgendwie so
irgendwie in diese Richtung und also die
also merk ich konnte diese Authentizität
in diesen Geschichten nicht mehr halten
weil meine Kinder eben halt dann da was
von abbekommen hätten habe ich damit
aufgehört ja guckst du denn auch noch
spetterfilme ja klar Logo es gibt ja
diesen wunderbaren Festivals ich glaube
die gibt's bei euch in Köln auch die
gibt glaub ich momentan in allen
deutschen großen Städten dieses Horror
Fantasy
Festival liebe ich ja ist eine Woche
lang wirklich nur die Freaks
untereinander die da diese Filme lieben
und es ist auch so dass dann wenn
irgendwie man in ist ja hentlich in die
Sendezeit wo ich das sagen darf wenn
dann wirklich ein schöner Mord passiert
und dann vollkommen skorile Geschichte
da dann stehen die auch auf und
klatschen ne also in in das ist dann
schon toll wenn man wir nehmen uns
natürlich da nicht ernst im Sinne von
sondern wir lieben dieses diesen diesen
diese Monstrosität der Fantasie dieses
überbordende abstruse dieses dieses
dieses human Fiction
das ist das was uns oder uns Horrors
Fenster oder spletter Fans irgendwie
verbindet was ich habe also bei allen
meinen Freundin die mir ernst waren s
meine Hand voll ich bin echt
Frauenheld also auch mit allen one stand
und so da komme ich nicht auf da kommen
ich also nicht auf besonders viele da
könn ich also kein Buch drüber schreiben
also die die mir wirklich ernst waren
mit ich dann auch darüber gesprochen
habe warum ich gerne solche Sachen sehe
oder lese oder so ich konnte es nie
erklären ich habe mich immer bemüht zu
erklären warum bis ich dann irgendwann
mal aufgegeben habe Gag entweder du du
kommst jetzt mit guckst mittlerweise so
dass ich nur noch alleine in solche
Filme gehe weil es ist natürlich
unglaublich unerotisch wenn der Zombie
die Tür Eintritt mit einer Kettensäge
die Familie niedermetzelt der Vater ihm
die Mikrowelle auf den Schädel Haut und
die Mikrowelle anspringt und das Monster
stirbt und deine Freundin neben dir sagt
jetzt aber unlogischich der ganze Film
kaputt deswegen gehe ich da nicht re
oder gehen wir da nicht rein um Iras
logisches zu erleben für mich ist es
genauso unlogisch wie in einer Weltstadt
wie New York Tom hangst genau in dem
Apartment wohnt wo seine seine Freundin
gerade E-Mail absickt gerade e-Mail für
dich aber diese Geschichten mit dem
Herzen die dürfen immer ab sein und
sobald ein Monster irgendwie anfängt
absurd zu sein rcht sich der ganze Kino
auf also von daher Stopp das machen wir
nicht mehr WST du ja gerne selber drin
mitspielen aber natürlich natürlich
meine di es ist ja so dass sie natürlich
auch ien riesen Spaß haben ich Ken ja
mittlerweile was hinter der Kamera
passiert ist
ja also was mich wirklich das gut dass
du mich drauf ansprichst was mich
wirklich interessiert hat oder was ich
immer noch nicht geklärt habe für mich
und auch nie klären kann als damals
diese Linda BL den Exorzisten gemacht
hat da war die ja 12 oder 13 oder so und
ich frage mich immer ob das Mädchen
eigentlich während die sie gearbeitet
hat gemerkt hat was sie da eigentlich
produziert weil der Film ist echt vom
schrecklichsten das ist also wirklich
habe ich gesehen da war ich mit zwei
Freunden das war gerade nach dem Abitur
wir waren schon erwachsen wir haben uns
da irgendwie reingedrückt und saßen auf
dem Boden irgendwo hinten auf auf der
Nottreppe und der Film hat uns drein so
einen Schiss gemacht dass wir hinterer
echt wirklich zusammen also wir sind
dicke dicke Freunde geworden GL wir sind
eine Woche lang nicht mehr auseinander
gegangen wir sind ir ja auch aus Angst
aus Angst weil das Absurde an diesem
Film war ja dass dass wenn du wenn ich
irgendwie
ein Virus in mir habe was mich zum
irgendwas mutieren lässt kann ich immer
noch wenn ganz ganz schrecklich kommt
mich umbringen aber in diesem Fall war
es ja so wenn du um dich umbringst
kommst du ja sowieso in die Hölle und da
geht die ganze Scheiße von vorne los und
zwar für die Ewigkeit und dieser Gedanke
hat uns fertig gemacht wir hatten so
eine Angst davor dass wir echt wirklich
nächtelang auch zusammen geschlafen
haben also wirklich in komm komm spst du
nach bei mir ne ja ja ich auch das ist
eine richtige dicke Freundschaft
entstanden dadurch dass wir uns EAL eine
Woche nach dem Exorzisten nicht mehr
auseinander getraut haben also das ist
schon so dass man dass man dass man dass
ich da immer noch großen großen Hang zu
habe und ich erwische mich auch manchmal
dabei wie ich wenn wir zusammen sag mal
so ein Videoabend haben oder wir sind
sitzen alle zusammen wie ich dann auch
manchmal s s mal ganz kurz da weil du
merkst ja schon die Kinder gerade Johnny
und Luna die jetzt 12 13 sind die sind
natürlich auch schon wie war Monster
dann hat das Monster dann irgendwie ja
genau D hat er den oh und dann merke ich
schon die möchten das schon auch gerne
mal sehen ne und dann denk bin ich
manchmal so ein bisschen so am
provozieren s Papa mal reinmachen soll
mal gucken und so aber natürlich tu ich
es nicht aber ich merke im mal wie die
Kinder dann schon so große Augen kriegen
und dann auch gerne gucken möchten und
und da sind wir natürlich sofort beim
nächsten praktisch reingestolpert in die
Diskussion was ist jetzt mit unserer
Jugend und ihren Brutalo spielen oder
gewaltpielen was da jetzt passiert und
jetzt nach dem Amoklauf wieder alles
verboten werden soll also ganz ehrlich
wenn du mich fragst finde ich so eine
schwachsinnige Lösung jetzt zu sagen
durch diese amläufe lassen wir ein paar
egoshoooter Fallen dannach haben wir
irgendwie die Sache im Griff so ein
Schwachsinn ich habe mein Leben lang
wirklich EG Shooter gespielt nächtelang
durch kommt mir würde nicht ein eine
Sekunde auf die Idee kommen ir
irgendjemand irgendwie Leid anzutun auch
nicht wenn du total sauer auf dem bist
da haben doch die anderen nichts mit zu
tun irgendwie natürlich ist es immer so
dass man selbst meine Tochter irgendwie
das und da oh pass auf jetzt erzähle ich
dir was kom da bin ich nämlich als erst
mal richtig bewusst als Vater
aufgetreten habe ichmer mal zum Kegeln
gegangen und und irgendwann hat meine
Tochter dann mich irendwi ich merkte so
sie ließ sich zurückfallen und fing
plötzlich ganz bitterlich an zu weinen
und sagte Papa ich werde in der Schule
gemobt da sind irgendwelche Mädchen die
mögen ich weiß nicht warum aber
irgendwie komme ich da nicht zurecht
weinte bitterlich dann habe ich da mit
ihr geredet und so und dass sie ein
tolles Mädchen ist und überhaupt gar
nicht nötig hät und fing sie wieder an
zu lachen so ein lachwein und so und das
war dann haben wir uns auch ganz fest
gedrückt und so aber es ist schon so
dass dieses mobben was ich auch von
meinem zohn kenne der das mir auch
manchmal berichtet das hatten wir früher
in der Schule nicht wir haben uns
entweder auf mal so geschubt oder aufs
Maul geh en oder auch nicht gemocht aber
dann war auch gut aber dieses Mob e guck
mal wie die aussieht guck mal was die
anhat die stinkt ja irgendwie da kannst
ja Ben die sind richtig hart drauf ne
die S machen sich richtig
fettig und da habe ich als Papa glaube
ich zum ersten Mal auf dem Tablet auch
irgendwie so reagiert dass ich sie
wirklich bewusst gespürt habe ihr
Problem bewusst gespürt habe und ich
mich glaube ich auch gut verhalten habe
weil ich merkte irgendwand löst sich in
auf und wenn ich nur als Papa da war und
Ratgeber da war der vielleicht jetzt
auch nichts groß es geholfen hat aber
wenigstens da war das hat schon was
gebracht und daran erinnere ich mich z.B
das ist da da ich bin jetzt nicht sicher
ob es jetzt besser geworden ist oder ob
es irgendwie sowieso nur übertrieben war
oder gerade akut so schmerzte aber da
war sie wirklich am Boden zerstört und
da war ich froh dass dass ich da war und
da war sie auch froh dass ich da war und
das da merke ich schon dass ich eben Hal
als Vater jetzt nicht komplett
inkompetent bin ne nur eben halt nicht
das was ich eben halt als Vater jetzt
irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Vorbildern
oder rten Bildern kennen würde einer der
sowieso also ich würde auch zu meinen
Kindern nie sagen ist nicht so schlimm
weil ich weiß dass es schlimm ist aber
um das jetztch mal den Bogen zu schlagen
zu dem Amok laufen auch wenn die jetzt
gemobt worden ist und sagst so die kaufe
ich mir jetzt das ist ja nicht im Grunde
genommen nicht das Problem sondern das
Problem liegt ja darin dass du es dass
du kein kein Ventil hast um das zu lösen
mit irgendwas mit Gesprächen oder mit
mit der Mama oder mit dem Papa oder mit
den Freunden du hast dann irgendwie
plötzlich keinen mehr mit dem du das
lösen kannst mit dem du das Besprechen
kannst wo du das loswerden kannst
und das dann irgendwie so ein so ein aus
der Generation komme ich nicht ich bin
aus der Generation sprechen aus der
Generation mit anderen sowas lösen
irgendwie ne aber wenn man mit Kindern
umgeht ohne sie jetzt irgendwie zu
erziehen im sin ah habe ich erzogen B
habe ich auch gemacht C habe ich auch
gemacht sondern dass sie einfach in
einem System groß werden wo sie geliebt
werden anerkannt werden normal mit
umgegangen wird scheint es schon zu
genügen denn ich habe dazu nichts
beigetragen also nichts bewusstes wo ich
jetzt sagen kann aha da ist meine
Handschrift drin oder so kann ich nicht
nicht behaupten ja wir müssen Schluss
machen wir könnten glaube ich noch ewig
reden ja stimmt viel Erfolg auf jeden
Fall bei der Kindererziehung auch wenn
sie vielleicht unbewusst läuft aber
offensichtlich erfolgreich ah das ist
nicht so schlecht ja das nehme ich gerne
mit danke schön